oh did I take one please
hey good evening how are you very well
in yourself well thank you I'm sorry my
name is David Davis so what do you do I
am actually the restaurant manager here
I thought I just met the restaurant the
little man the other restaurant manager
and the food have you waiting food out
of 10 6 6 I wouldn't serve any of our
dishes to my dog chef Brian's kind of
given up so much has been taken out of
Brian's hands via that I don't think
that he has the passion and the drive to
be that great anymore starting off with
chicken under a break what does actually
mean it means it's drier than about
amazing even the manager thinks the
food's terrible here and he's not
embarrassed to tell me and then the
capita say cavatappi yeah here we go
with chicken subtitle multiple options
you know I want no [ __ ] really I'm still
gonna try it so for dessert I'll go for
the chocolate pig the 10 inch dessert
pizza chocolate strawberries Baker how
can I resist that thank you actually
the table I'm wringing right now just
bring it as it comes okay everything's
under fire
all right what do we have here this is
the break chicken $21 $21 break chicken
yeah it looks like someone just shot a
break Morini
that's actually better than usual ready
yeah chicken under a brick is where it
should have stayed because it should
have never come out of the kitchen
Wow pardon my reaching okay this is the
cavatappi and chicken okay
bland chickens try way too much
Rosemarie and just it's [ __ ]
at least I say we were dessert well you
have here is the chocolate poop white
and dark chocolate strawberries baby
it's like we've had a crisis with the
toilet paper Department someone's wipe
their ass with my daughter I mean it's
just I've never seen anything so [ __ ]
unappetizing as a dessert and all my
life absolutely bacon and chocolate
pizza OMFG yes you didn't like any of it
no one day [ __ ] me